Salut la team mentalo !
Quand je rencontre quelqu'un et que je lui explique que je fais une vidéo par jour pendant un an, la première question qu'il me pose, c'est:
"Donc tu n'as vraiment que ça à foutre ?!"
Non, ça c'est ce qu'il pense, mais la question c'est:
"Tu n'as pas peur de tomber en panne d'inspiration ?"
Et bien non !
Alors je ne suis pas plus créatif que vous à la base. Mais la créativité ça s'apprend.
Et aujourd'hui je vais vous donner les techniques que j'utilise et que vous allez aussi pouvoir utiliser.
Premièrement, donnez un bon gros coup de pied dans la fourmilière.
La routine, ça empêche l'innovation.
Alors je en dis pas qu'en cassant les habitudes vous allez avoir tout de suite, instantanément des éclairs de génie,
mais ça va vous ouvrir à d'autres choses.
Vous pouvez aller dans des endroits complètement improbables en vacances
vous pouvez faire du covoiturage, vous pouvez prendre un autre chemin que celui de d'habitude pour aller à l'école ou à votre travail le matin...
Vous pouvez ranger votre maison, ou votre chambre, votre bureau complètement différemment en réordonnant un petit peu tout.
Vous pouvez aussi aller voir un spectacle que vous n'iriez pas voir du tout à la base, même de l'opéra ou de la danse, ou un spectacle comique qui ne vous concerne pas habituellement.
Que vous cherchiez à être plus créatif dans votre vie professionnelle, personnelle, culturelle, artistique...Peu importe.
Vous allez vous ouvrir à d'autres pensées que vous n'auriez pas eu dans votre routine et dans votre train-train habituel.
Pour ça, à chaque fois que vous cassez la routine, faites une espèce d'auto analyse.
Parlez vous à vous même: "Tiens, qu'est-ce que je peux retirer de ça ? Quelle idée ça m'amènerait ? Comment je pourrai en bénéficier ? Comment je pourrai m'en servir... ?"
Deuxième technique: soyez un enfant !
Faites comme eux ! Quand on est petit, on ne se pose pas la question, on ne se juge pas, on teste plein de choses, on teste plein d'idées, sans se juger sur le résultat de l'idée en elle-même.
Au lieu d'écrire sur une feuille de papier, dessinez à la place,
quand vous avez un problème, faites-en un jeu, c'est-à-dire, trouvez des règles, vraiment, des objectifs... jouez avec ce problème là.
Posez vous des questions complètement décalées sur ce que vous avez à faire pour avoir un angle de vue complètement différent.
Troisième technique que j'utilise beaucoup, c'est changer l'ordre des choses.
En ce moment je suis en train d'écrire mon nouveau spectacle pour l'année prochaine,
et je ne travaille pas du tout du début du spectacle jusqu'à la fin du spectacle.
En fait je travaille sur pleins de choses en même temps.
Et même dans ces "pleins de choses", je ne les fais pas forcément dans l'ordre.
J'écris des petits bouts un petit peu partout, sans forcément les finir.
Chaque idée est développé individuellement et des fois ça m'emmène vers d'autres choses,
et l'emballage, la finalité, ça je la verrai plus tard, à la fin.
Quatrième technique qui est un peu la reine des techniques dont on parle en créativité mais qui est vraiment efficace, c'est le brainstorming !
Générez des idées aléatoirement.
Vous écrivez un mot sur une feuille. Vous écrivez votre mot, et ensuite vous écrivez 5 mots qui vous font penser à ce mot là.
Par exemple si j'écris "SPECTACLE" ici,
je vais peut-être écrire "PUBLIC",
je vais peut-être écrire... "THEATRE".
Je vais écrire comme ça 5 mots qui me font penser à ce mot là.
Et ensuite vous allez écrire 5 mots aux 5 mots que vous avez déjà écrit.
Donc 25 mots de plus, et les 5 mots à chaque fois en rapport avec le mot.
Par exemple après "PUBLIC", je vais écrire 5 mots en lien avec le public.
Et pour terminer, vous prenez 2 des 25 mots que vous avez écrit, et vous essayez de les associer ensemble.
Des fois il ne va rien se passer. Souvent il ne va rien se passer même.
Mais des fois ça va vous faire une connexion que vous n'auriez pas eue à la base et ça va vous donner l'idée du siècle !
Cinquième technique, ma préférée !
Utilisez des mindmap.
La carte mentale !
Alors c'est un petit peu comme le brainstorming mais en beaucoup moins aléatoire.
J'ai d'ailleurs fait déjà une vidéo dessus que je vais vous mettre ici et en lien dans le descriptif.
Me concernant, c'est l'outil le plus puissant que je peux utiliser aussi bien pour la mémoire que pour la créativité.
Je ne vais pas complètement le détailler puisque j'ai déjà fait une vidéo là-dessus, mais disons que pour un exemple concret,
si vous recherchez un appartement, vous écrivez "APPARTEMENT" avec une bulle entourée,
et là je vais commencer à faire des connexions, et dans chacune de ces connexions de ces bulles la, je mettre une technique pour trouver un appartement.
Agence immobilière, chasseurs d'appartement, petites annonces, réseaux sociaux, applications sur le téléphone portable, émissions de télévision pourquoi pas.
Et ensuite pour chacune de ces bulles là que j'aurais fait, je vais écrire les avantages et les inconvénients,
et peut-être aussi les moyens de les contacter.
Bref, je vais me faire une carte comme ça de toutes ces possibilités.
Et à la fin, peu importe pourquoi vous faites ce travail la, vous allez avoir une vision très claire de tous les chemins possibles.
Très pratique !
La créativité c'est ni plus ni moins le jeu de Mario Bros.
C'est-à-dire, il faut savoir tomber et se vautrer un petit peu, pour pouvoir aller de plus en plus loin.
Donc en phase de créativité, ne vous jugez pas, à aucun moment.
Ne pensez pas encore au résultat final, c'est beaucoup trop tôt pour le faire.
Ne vous censurez pas !
Essayez, tenez et laissez vous aller.
J'espère vraiment que cette vidéo elle vous aidera, aujourd'hui ou meme dans le futur.
Si vous, vous utilisez d'autres techniques de créativité, que vous les trouvez intéressantes,
n'hésitez pas à les mettre dans les commentaires pour en faire bénéficier tout le monde.
Toute la team mentalo !
Pour info, j'ai un tout petit peu de retard.
Demain je ferrai la vidéo du tirage au sort, du concours qu'on a fait la semaine dernière et je vous mettrai un lien dans la vidéo de demain pour aller voir les résultats du concours.
Faites preuve d'une magnifique créativité artistique en laissant un pouce en l'air à cette vidéo.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de...
Non c'est par là ? [cherche le logo "s'abonner"]
Oui...
De vous abonnez avant de partir.
Puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour, durant toute une année.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17H !
Ciao !
Je joue mon spectacle en entier le 23 septembre à la Garenne-Colombes, c'est la date la plus proche de Paris, si jamais vous voulez venir sinon, il y a toutes les dates de tournée sur mon site !